it is seven o'clock good to see you this
monday morning
genocide that's how ukraine's deputy
prime minister views what's happening in
her country
overnight fresh evidence of a fatal
attack on a residential area in kiev the
health secretary sergeant javid will be
on the show shortly
also being able to update us on the
rising numbers of covered infections
plus with evidence suggesting russian
advances on kiev are stalling we'll be
talking to the former uk national
security adviser peter ricketts and the
first prosecutor of the un criminal
tribunal for the former yugoslavia and
rwanda to ask whether vladimir putin
will ever face a court and i'll be
speaking to the snp's ian blackford
heading to poland to bring back some
young ukrainian orphans to scotland it
is monday the 21st of march
civilian casualties
at least four people are killed as a
shopping center in the capital kiev is
hit by russian shells
the race to rescue a hand is spotted
amongst the rubble as firefighters pull
people out alive from a destroyed
building
we take you to the front line of the war
in kharkiv near ukraine's border with
russia with a special eyewitness report
from our correspondent john sparks
we're still inside the city
but it's a war zone it's a battlefield
tanks and heavy armaments
just about everywhere
the cost of living crisis sky news data
reveals that two and a half million
families will be in fuel poverty in
april amidst reports the chancellor may
cut fuel duty
boosting our chances against rising
covert cases the spring program to shore
up our defenses
labour is to force an emergency vote in
the commons to demand that ferry company
p o reinstates 800 workers who are
sacked without notice
also ahead on the programme
shining a spotlight on the crisis i'll
be speaking to the stars aj and curtis
pritchard ahead of a major theatrical
fundraiser for ukraine
[Music]
and banned in a bunker we'll speak to
the ukrainians who are rallying the
troops fighting in the streets above
them
[Music]
morning all claims of genocide a fresh
attack on a residential part of the
capital a new intelligence suggesting
the russian advance on the capital is
stalling certainly plenty to update you
this morning on from ukraine
at least four people have been killed by
russian shelling on a shopping center in
kiev the latest mlg intelligence
suggests that russian forces advancing
on the capital have stalled more than 25
kilometers from the centre of the city
ukraine well it's rejected a russian
demand that its troops defending the
besieged city of mariopol lay down their
weapons and leave and both ukraine's
president and deputy prime minister have
now accused russia of genocide
authorities in sumi have reported an
ammonia leak at a chemical plant and
designated a hazardous zone five
kilometers around the site
well let's look at what happened in kiev
overnight russian shelling hitting homes
and a shopping district in the process
killing at least four people
security camera footage showed a huge
explosion followed by a series of
smaller blasts at a shopping center in
the podal district
this is the moment that one man is
rescued from the rubble by firefighter
his outstretched hand was spotted by
emergency workers rushing to rescue
people from the building
i will speak now to our special
correspondent alex crawford uh joining
us now from kiev alex good to see you
this morning um i mean we've just been
reporting on that mod intelligence
briefing suggesting that the russians
are still stuck some 25 kilometers from
the centre of the capital but as the
scene behind you reveals they don't have
to be there to destroy the place
they definitely don't and certainly near
the center we're about 10 kilometers
away from our center it feels very
secure people are definitely
beginning to come back out onto the
streets even shops and some restaurants
are opening
they're planting flowers they feel quite
secure i think right in the center but
from even from where we were we could
hear the volley of explosions late last
night and if i just step away and show
you there's a massive amount of
devastation and of course not only is
this a gym a huge big shopping center
it's also in the heart of an industrial
area and behind us and in front of this
blast there are
residential homes and flats and many of
them have had their windows blown out
and the fronts um
shattered so and we know according to um
the police so far there are about four
confirmed deaths the the locals here in
the the people who are living all around
who are utterly terrified who've been
speaking to a few of them
this morning believe that the number of
casualties could be much higher and of
course it's not just the it's not just
the um the devastation it's causing it's
the absolute terrorist terrifying
moments that you're going through when a
volley of of rockets and missiles are
landing right next to you people talk
about it feeling like an earthquake and
they're absolutely terrified even if
they're not actually in caught up and
hurt themselves they're very scared so
vitalik the mayor of kiev is um
giving a very defiant message and saying
that they're never going to give in but
there's a lot of of terror once again on
the streets of of kiev
alex many thanks
uh we're joined in the studio now once
again by the health secretary sergeant
minister great to have you good morning
on the programme um
let's just reflect of course plenty to
talk about in terms of your brief but
let's reflect on what we have seen
coming out of ukraine over the past 24
hours i personally have watched more
footage from ukraine than i would care
to ever admit to but this weekend seeing
children being pulled out of the rubble
kind of brought it home to me
is the british government yet to the
point where they can they can join
the ukrainian president ukrainian deputy
prime minister in describing what we're
seeing in ukraine as a as a genocide
look like everyone i'm appalled by the
the scenes coming out of ukraine right
now the despicable attacks on civilians
when i was last in your studio that was
a day we saw the picture of that the the
woman from a maternity hospital a
pregnant woman that'd be murdered uh by
the russians and now we're seeing
children being pulled out of rubble it's
in terms of um holding russia
accountable in russia and the president
putin he will absolutely be held
accountable for this
there's a there's an international
criminal court that will
work on this and they're already uh
compiling evidence the deputy prime
minister was in the hague last week uh
offering the uk's full support to hold
russia to account in the meantime we
will of course will continue to support
the ukrainians in every single way that
we can
i i do wonder though we heard from the
the former prime minister gordon brown
at the weekend pointing out the problems
that there may well be with the
international criminal court process the
least not least of which is there's not
a chance that we're going to be able to
extradite vladimir putin from russia to
face charges directly what do you make
of his suggestion that there is perhaps
a nuremberg style trial set up to try
and prosecute this which we can
prosecute an obscenity if necessary look
i think all of that should be looked at
i think it's right that uh gordon brown
and others many people are thinking
about the the what ways and mechanisms
can the international community use to
hold russia to account i mean right here
and now i think it's really important
that we and our allies continue to
support russia in er because supporting
ukraine in in every way
with the military aid that we're
providing i think more than any other
country the humanitarian support that
we're providing as well all of this is
crucial but also making sure that russia
is held to account i i understand that
this is not your brief i understand that
that all cabinet ministers will want to
be careful with their language but but i
will note that you don't feel
comfortable going as far as the
as the ukrainian president and and being
literal about this stating that in your
view given what we have seen you feel
that he's committing accidents what
president zielenski thinks is very very
important to us we of course will listen
to him carefully the prime minister our
prime minister
talks to him on a regular basis and we
will help the ukrainians gather all the
evidence they need for successful
prosecutions whenever we can where are
we at the moment with the scheme to
raise house ukrainians coming to the
united kingdom um 3.4 million people
have fled the country at the moment and
the concerns are particularly from
agencies working in non-governmental
organizations working in this field is
that we're not being quick enough to
match people up well my understanding is
with this so there's two schemes at the
moment with the family reunification
scheme i think some nine and a half
thousand visas have been issued
with the hosting a ukrainian family
scheme i think some over 150 000 people
have registered their interest and the
process of matching those hosts uh with
with families from ukraine has begun
can i just ask about something that the
home secretary mentioned at the weekend
which i haven't really seen picked up
particularly widely we know that we have
had a different approach as regards
visas for ukrainians coming to this
country she said this the truth is that
a very small number of people can wreak
utter havoc and russia has a history of
covert hostile activity
are we really suggesting that we believe
that there could be russian agents
coming to this country under false
ukrainian passports and that's what the
home secretary is suggesting and she's
right too by the way to to point that
out
let's let's let's just what end would
russia be coming in in that fashion we
know the russians have done that they
did it in 2018 when i had her job
and we
we saw in our country russian agents
came here with a deadly nerve agent a
chemical weapon
and they used it in salisbury
we know it killed people and russia was
directly responsible for that they
infiltrated our country with agents with
a chemical weapon and used it and so it
is right there there are some level of
of security checks we also know that
extremists and extremist organizations
operate in that region of course the the
level of security checks has to be
proportionate uh to the the the issues
that we're dealing with the example that
you get at the same time getting the way
of of letting ukrainians come here to
safety sure but the example you gave of
salisbury my understanding is those two
russians arrived on a russian passport
on a tourist visa
in what way would these these security
checks stop them coming well it wouldn't
be it wouldn't make sense to get into
detail about how our checks work uh
precisely but i think most people would
understand that we do what we can to
protect our homeland let you've been
very good so let's talk on uh on
speaking away from your brief so let's
move on to it covered cases are clearly
on the upswing at the moment do you have
an estimate of when we might reach the
peak
um i think with omicron
we have
we're past the peak down we've come down
from that level the although infections
are rising case numbers are rising and
hospitalizations have risen a bit as
well over the last two weeks they're
still way below their peak it's also
worth uh sort of keeping in mind why
we're seeing rises that was always going
to be the case when we opened up and
also we have a sub-variant let's call it
of the original omicron called ba2 which
we know on the one hand is more
infectious than the original omicron
variant but
thankfully these vaccines that we have
are just as effective against
it why is it taking so long to get to
this next stage of the role but my
reckoning we're about six months away
from the start of the third dose scheme
and we know of course that resistance
wins a lot quicker than you know within
six months should we perhaps have got to
this point slightly quicker or is it all
because of the jcvi no i think we're
exactly the the right places when it
comes to vaccine waning and
effectiveness it's something we monitor
almost on a daily basis i think as a
country we've probably done more
research on that than any other country
but this is winning resistance part of
the reason why we are seeing increased
infections increased i think i think the
the primary reasons are the ones i
mentioned which are increased uh social
mixing and uh also this ba2 subvariant
the announcement today which is a a
spring booster dose
for those that are over 75 elderly
people living in care homes and the
immunosuppressed this will allow that
group of people which are at more
serious risk than others to top up their
protection against this virus and and
and give them that extra level of
confidence that they need is it not
somewhat counterintuitive at a point
which we're suggesting that over 75
people who are vulnerable should be able
to get a fourth dose that we're about a
fortnight away from the ending of free
covert testing
um no i don't think the the two things
are necessarily related i mean our
primary
when we
do not think that if you remove free
testing fewer people will test
well obviously if there's fewer tests
around then than fuel will be used but
the the question really is do we still
need to have a universal free testing
offer which is as it sounds yes for
everyone whenever they want to test and
our determination based on the advice
that we received that is no longer
necessary we're in a much better stage
with kobe than we have been so far
clearly it's still there that's why we
still need to keep focusing on our
defenses but the best defense is
vaccination we've built a wall of
defense it's working in fact i think
this weekend the uk health security
agency they said in their analysis that
since december because of the booster
push that we had we've kept some 157 000
people out of hospital so vaccines work
and that is why everyone that's eligible
please should come forward
just just briefly should we expect a
broader rollout of a fourth dose well
the jcvi that's our group of independent
advisors they have said they are looking
at a autumn dose for over 50s but
there's no final decision at this point
in time can we just reflect just a
briefly
going back to ukraine on the comments
that the prime minister made at the
weekend drawing a comparison in his mind
between
voting to leave the european union and
fighting against a russian invasion of
ukraine did you think it was appropriate
he seemed to suggest that those who who
didn't vote against brexit like yourself
were somehow not lovers of freedom
well i i heard his comments and i don't
think he was suggesting that at all what
i heard from the prime minister was uh
the basically the desire for
self-determination in in everyone no
matter what country they're in no matter
what their circumstance is strong i
don't think in any way he was connecting
the situations in ukraine and the uk and
if we want to know what the prime
minister thinks about ukraine and
responding i mean we can see for
ourselves in terms of the support that
he's provided you know rock solid
support compared to any other world
leader you don't you don't think it was
a tall crass for the prime minister to
make that comparison or to allude to a
comparison i mean the perp the british i
don't i don't think i don't accept that
he was comparing the uk he mentioned one
and he mentioned the other in the city
his point his point was about
the importance of self-determination and
and people you know whoever they are
wherever they are they have this strong
feeling of wanting to have freedom and
determine i'm just i'm just generally
suggesting that the self-determination
you know shown by the brits who voted to
leave a political and economic union
it's not the same as the
self-determination shown by people who
are picking up guns and firing on
invaders
and he wasn't saying i think it's
spurious to say that he was connecting
somehow
in that way well i i i think most normal
people listening to that wouldn't have
drawn that conclusion i think you can
see what he's talking about which is
just about the importance of
self-determination just just a final
point of course on all eyes this week on
what the chancellor does come come
wednesday and you i'm sure will not be
drawn on perhaps more money for your or
whatever else but just in terms of the
strategy currently isn't isn't the
single biggest beneficiary of the rise
in the cost of living right now the the
treasury that any wiggle room that the
treasury has right now is down to
increase tax take at the petrol pumps
v80 and so on well look one of the
benefits of no longer being chancellor
is i don't really have to answer those
questions
sadie javits we'll leave it there thanks
for being with us thank you
now and the war in ukraine is of course
dominating the front pages of the papers
once again uh here is the telegraph
it reports on accusations that vladimir
putin has ordered the abduction of
thousands of ukrainians from mario paul
forcing them
deporting them to
remote russian cities in fact at the
guardian also leading with that u.s
ambassador to the u.n saying that if
those reports are true
then it's disturbing and unconscionable
the times describes the abduction of
civilians with the headline russia
accused of genocide
here is the mirror it reports on the
deadline for p bosses to explain the
decision to sack 800 workers
now ukraine has accused russia of
committing acts of genocides it follows
the bombing of an art school in mariopol
where 400 people mostly women and
children had taken refuge and in a
further sign of just how attritional the
battle for the country's major cities is
becoming
russian-backed separatists said that
they had used devastating so-called
vacuum bombs to try and break the
deadlock but there are signs that in
some places the two sides are fighting
themselves towards a standstill the city
of kharkiv just a short drive from the
border with russia certainly bears the
scars of vicious fighting but also some
signs of a stalemate our correspondent
john sparks traveled with the ukrainian
military to the front line on the
outskirts of kharkiv just a warning this
report does contain pictures of the
bodies of russian soldiers
the most desirable homes in the city of
harkiev are located within its northern
suburbs
but no one comes here now
unless you man a checkpoint
or carry a weapon
or drive a t-72 tank
on the outskirts of the country's second
largest city the ukrainians and the
russians take pot shots in the woods
as the ukrainian army awaits the enemy's
next move
we're still inside the city
but it's a war zone it's a battlefield
[Music]
tanks and heavy armaments
just about everywhere
we were given access to the suburban
frontier and taken to a children's camp
in the trees
with mock turrets and cabins and areas
to play
have pierced the grounds and a rocket
hit the door
our guide did not want to show his face
it's actually punctured the door around
here the rocket
inserted itself through the metal frame
nearby we found a soldier called doc
he'd been planting land mines when the
shells came in what did you see what did
you experience
a few minutes later we had to use his
shelter
grad rockets incoming
the signs of war are all around with the
remnants of a russian column littering
the trees
it's a sign of what the ukrainian army
is able to achieve
in the suburbs of harkiv the russian
advance has ground to a halt
and in a gruesome display of grit and
intent we were taken to see the bodies
of five dead russian servicemen
a ukrainian captain claiming the
russians have refused to repatriate the
bodies
the battle may have stalled but it
certainly isn't over
everyone in this city is sure of that
so they prepare themselves for the
seemingly inevitable regardless of the
personal cost
john sparks sky news in harkev
and we will have more uh from john
sparks and indeed mark stone on the
polish border uh throughout the program
this morning but just a little bit of
breaking news uh the chinese foreign
ministry uh talking about the the crisis
in ukraine says this the chinese red
cross is to offer an additional 10
million yuan of humanitarian assistance
to ukraine plenty of discussion in
diplomatic circles at the moment as to
how to leverage
china's relationship with the kremlin
but stay where you are plenty still to
come on the program this morning as
russia's advance on ukraine city's years
just appears to be stolen i'll be
speaking to the former uk national
security adviser peter
ricketts i'll also be joined by the
first prosecutor of the un criminal
tribunal for the former yugoslavia and
rwanda judge richard goldstein
and as fuel prices skyrocket i'll be
speaking to the executive director of
the petrol retailers association
[Music]
sky news can reveal that two and a half
million families will be in fuel poverty
when the new energy price cap comes into
effect at the start of april a family is
deemed to be in fuel poverty if more
than 10 of its income is spent on those
bills
since february of last year the annual
price of a standard energy tariff has
increased by more than 800 pounds to
almost 2000.
areas in the west and east midlands and
london are the worst affected some 40 of
households in these parts
are likely to experience fuel poverty
in scotland meanwhile
more than nine hundred thousand
households are also expected to be fuel
fuel poor under the new cap with
two-thirds of them in extreme fuel
poverty
uh excuse melinda veselnovic has been
taking a look at the numbers and joins
us now from the newsroom good to see you
this morning melinda it's all very
concerning all very worrying but
particularly the figures millions of
people are going to be struggling very
very soon
good morning neil very concerning
overall the figures show that a quarter
of people in england are going to be
fuel poor as of friday after next when
the cost of a standard bill will rise by
50 percent and now that's 15 million
people and sky news analysis has shown
that the worst place in the country is
going to be bushberry and low hill area
of wolverhampton where up to 9 in 10
people will be fuel poor and that's
particularly concerning when you look at
medical research by the british medical
journal which clearly lings children
growing up in damn cold homes with poor
health outcomes now in scotland the
situation is also going to be very dire
shows that 40 of households there
will be fewer poor and two-thirds of
that number are expected to be in
extreme fuel poverty and that means
they're spending 20 percent of their
income on energy now
the government has announced plans to
try to help this situation some alone
some rebates and but all eyes are now on
chancellor rishi sunig and what he will
say in his spring statement
marina thank
you and we will of course have live
coverage of the chancellor's spring
statement
that's due on wednesday and we'll be
starting our coverage from 11 o'clock
here on sky news
also making the news this morning labour
is expected to force an emergency vote
to ban fire and rehire practices and to
demand that the ferry company pando take
back their workforce
the mass sackings without notice have
caused outrage nationwide amidst reports
that security firms with balaclavas and
handcuffs were used to take sacked
british workers off the vessels
the foreign office says that murat tabas
who holds british u.s and iranian
citizenship is now at a hotel in tehran
having been freed from jail last week at
the same time as nazanin zagari
radcliffe and anusha shuri
mr tabas was not able to leave the
country with the other two detainees the
foreign officers say they're working
hard to get mr tabas back to the uk
two men have died whilst queuing for
four hours for fuel in sri lanka
as the country reckons with the most
severe economic crisis in its history
supply shortages on the island have also
caused millions of school exams to be
cancelled due to a lack of paper
the international monetary fund has
indicated that it would be willing to
discuss a financial bailout for the
nation
smacking children is now illegal in
wales the new law means that children
now have the same protection from
physical violence as adults
and that anyone looking after a child
can now face charges if they're found to
have physically disciplined them
smacking children is already illegal in
scotland and child protection charities
are now calling for the same measures to
be introduced in england
and in the next hour i'll be speaking to
wales deputy minister for social
services julie morgan
now the royals caribbean tour didn't
exactly start out as planned after
villagers in belize refused to let them
onto their land
but then
we had this at the duke and duchess of
cambridge at manny stood here uh to get
the spring back in their step quickly
enough uh william and kate as you can
see actually i think kate's rather
better than the future king how they
danced with local school children rolled
cocoa beans and were welcomed by local
families on the second day of their
visit
but as the russian invasion continues
ukrainians are finding new ways to be
heard
and appeal for international support
[Music]
their own twist on the clashes london
calling that proceeds from their war
anthem kiev calling recorded near the
front line will help fund an alert
system to warn the population of threats
and lobby for international support
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that will do quite well
let's take you through some of the best
pictures making the morning's papers and
we start with the express
the great
escape uh they expressed reporting on a
man who has dug by hand a tunnel to his
garden shed it's still reinforced fully
lit and carpeted
and it took three years to complete
colin furzi acknowledged it would be
quicker to walk to his shed but said it
was more fun to use the tunnel
particularly if it rains okay just a
reminder as to our top stories this hour
and at least four people have been
killed as a shopping center in the
capital kiev is hit by russian shelling
a hand is spotted amongst the rubble as
firefighters pull people out alive from
a destroyed building
and sky news data reveals that two and a
half million families will be in fuel
poverty in april amidst reports the
chancellor may well cut fuel
now just a short time ago i asked the
health secretary if he agreed with
ukrainian's the ukrainian leadership
that russia is committing genocide and
whether or not he supported the former
prime minister gordon brown's calls for
an international nuremberg style
tribunal for vladimir putin
in in terms of um holding russia
accountable in russia and the president
putin he will absolutely be held
accountable for this
there's a there's an international
criminal court that will
work on this and they're already
compiling evidence the deputy prime
minister was in the hague last week uh
offering the uk's full support to hold
russia to account i think it's right
that uh gordon brown and others many
people are thinking about the the what
ways and mechanisms can the
international community used to hold
russia
to account i mean right here and now uh
i think it's really important that we
and our allies continue to support
russia
support ukraine in in every way
with the military aid that we're
providing
as you can see our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen is here
with us uh good to see you tomorrow and
what did we make of that which we had um
from the the health secretary there he's
in a bit of a difficult position it's
not his brief but
given what we're seeing in ukraine it's
becoming very obvious that there is a
line in terms of the language the
government does not want to cross yes
absolutely what words can we use to
describe the absolute horrors that we've
seen and in some cases only heard about
from the city of mariopol and elsewhere
in ukraine not genocide according to the
health secretary we've seen british
politicians including the prime minister
being willing to use words like war
crimes being committed it's always been
the government's position that genocide
is a decision for international courts
which i think accounts for their
reticence there it is usually an
international court's uh decision to
describe a genocide as having happened
there's a un convention dating back to
the 1940s on that but because it has
always been very difficult and a very
long process to get the international
criminal court in the hague to actually
determine something as a genocide i
think they've only been um three that
they've ever determined including bosnia
they took a long time to go to that
point indeed a lot of other obviously
very strong contenders that other people
have called genocides that's why you're
seeing the likes of gordon brown and
interestingly john major as well backed
this called if you can't get the
international criminal court which the
uk is trying very hard to do dominic rob
was there last week
talking to them about getting them to
examine the evidence perhaps you could
have some other kind of hearing to try
and bring russia to account because the
scenes that we're seeing on our screens
at the moment people want to see someone
brought to account but even when a
genocide is determined it can be very
difficult for those who committed it to
then be put into prison
certainly can tomorrow for now thanks
very much indeed
now russian forces advancing on kiev
from the northeast have stalled uh the
latest defense intelligence report from
the minister of defence says that the
bulk of russian forces remain more than
25 kilometers from the center of the
city joining us once again on the
program peter ricketts former permanent
under secretary from the foreign
commonwealth office also national
security advisor frankly your cv goes on
peter so we'll leave it there but i
wonder if we could start our
conversation this morning with the topic
that i was just discussing with tamara
in terms of the language being used by
the government you know sorry used to be
the hardest word for this government
genocide and war criminal why have they
made that decision
i don't know why they've made that
decision i mean it is as your
correspondent said a decision for
international courts whether the legal
test of a genocide has been passed i'm
not a lawyer and i can't tell you
whether that's the case but it's clear
to me that war crimes are being
committed
crimes against humanity which is another
of the definitions that the
international criminal court look at the
advantage of the international criminal
court is that it exists it is set up the
prosecutor is as i understand it already
collecting the evidence and it's vital
that he has all the evidence he needs
how exactly these crimes are going to be
prosecuted in the future you know i
don't think he's clear now but let's
make sure we have all the evidence so
that a future court can decide and how
exactly the crimes that are being
committed should be described in legal
terms
um peter given what we are seeing at the
moment on the ground in ukraine the
encircling of kiev yes the the advance
is stalled but they're they're shelling
the city you know
to destruction at the moment given what
we've seen in mario paul do you have any
confidence that there is a diplomatic
solution to the war
no i don't to be absolutely honest
certainly not in the foreseeable future
i think it's clear the russians cannot
win an outright victory ukrainian
resistance has been far too strong for
that we've seen even in mario poll after
weeks and weeks of smashing that city to
pieces people are not ready to surrender
to russian forces how much more
difficult would that be in a massive
city like uh kiev they are clearly
stalled bogged down all kinds of
problems with their logistics um i don't
think that they are ready yet to declare
any kind of a ceasefire negotiation the
positions of the two sides are far too
far apart for that i fear we're headed
for a long grinding campaign where the
russians try and smash one town after
another in the hope of breaking the will
of the ukrainian people
i think we're in for a stalemate rather
than a negotiated solution um as our
viewers can see on the bottom of the
screen at the moment the chinese foreign
ministry has announced additional
funding for humanitarian purposes in
ukraine which i'm sure will be warmly
received but in terms of the
relationship that the chinese have with
this conflict do you detect any sign
that they are willing to use their
influence over the kremlin to try and
bring about a speedier end to this or
are they just in a holding path and a
wait and see situation for them
i think they are as usual just looking
out for their own interests frankly um
they uh it quite suits them for the
americans and the europeans to be tied
down in uh
east of europe
for the russians to be
in difficulties puts them more and more
at
china's mercy in terms of a more
dependent relationship with china i
think china is looking to see how it can
come out of this best it doesn't want to
get too close to putin in case putin
fails massively which would tarnish the
chinese president so yes they're holding
back humanitarian aid they will make
gestures to show that they're not happy
with an invasion of an independent
country but if the
russians and the west bogged down in a
long war china will probably see in a
cynical way that that rather suits them
and their drive for the dominant power
in nation in the future
i mean clearly our defence budget our
standing in the world
means that we do have a role to play in
in trying to sort out the situation in
ukraine i'm just wondering
how much influence we we really have i
understand the prime minister is off to
the nato summit on thursday but he's not
been invited unlike joel biden to the eu
leaders summit on the same day
well in a way i don't think that's very
surprising i mean given the sort of
remarks he's been making over the
weekend uh about a comparing brexit to
the struggle of the ukrainian people i
mean that was seen as desperately
insulting and insensitive all around
europe i'm afraid we are not going to be
helping to shape the agenda with our eu
counterparts we should be
nato is an important forum for britain
as you say we're a major defence vendor
the uk has been very effective in
supplying aid and support to the
ukrainians
but in the crucial discussions that will
go on between joe biden and the
europeans for example on strengthening
sanctions britain is going to be on the
sidelines of that which i think is a
great mistake i think the prime minister
ought to be reaching out and working to
improve relations to heal the wounds of
the past with the eu not doubling down
on them
so
given what we are seeing in terms of the
the response you think the prime
minister was uh was was speaking in
crass terms was speaking in insulting
terms i just had the health secretary on
the program this morning sophie rich had
the chancellor on yesterday both of whom
saying look move away nothing to see
here he didn't make a direct comparison
they might have been watching a
different speech but it certainly looked
that way to me
the prime minister ought to be leading
the nation towards unity in this moment
of serious crisis in europe he ought to
be healing the wounds of the the brexit
debates and with europe he ought to be
rebuilding bridges um but it managed to
be uh insulting and insensitive i'm
afraid i think the best thing he could
do would be to withdraw the remark and
get back to working
in a sensible constructive way with the
europeans who are not some sort of
authoritarian force from which britain
sought its freedom they are our partners
and our allies in confronting this
massive threat to the security of all of
us in central europe
peter great to have you on the program
as always uh lord peter ricketts there
thank you for joining us
now ukraine has as we've been mentioning
accused russia of committing genocide
following the sustained bombing of the
port city of mario paul
joining us now former u.n chief
prosecutor for the criminal tribunal for
the former yugoslavia and rwanda richard
goldstone richard great to have your
expertise on on the programme this
morning
i wonder if we can just start with a
very very general question given your
experience of what took place in the
former yugoslavia and indeed in rwanda
looking at what you have seen emerge
from ukraine over the past four weeks
is there a prima facie case of war
crimes having been committed
well obviously their distinctions one
has to look at each situation of war
crimes and each
each war separately and and on its own
merits
um the word genocide
in my view unfortunately is too easily
bandied about
uh genocide is defined very clearly as
as as the intent it requires a special
intent
to destroy
in whole or in part
a racial or ethnic or religious uh group
uh the the evidence in the form
the evidence in ukraine
in my view
has
clearly has strong evidence of of of the
most serious war crimes and probably
crimes against humanity being being
committed
by
by the russian forces but but
certainly whether there's the intent on
the part of president putin and the
russian leaders to destroy the ukrainian
people is a very different question
from
from the sorts of attacks we are seeing
in fairness it must be said too that
that russia was the first to bendy about
the the word genocide russia has sought
to justify its attack
on the fact that genocide is allegedly
being committed by the ukrainians
against russian speakers in in the
northern parts of of of ukraine
that that was taken by by the ukraine
government of the international court of
justice the highest ue in court in the
hague and that court
came to the conclusion that that there
was some some evidence that russia was
misusing the word genocide as a false
premise as a false reason for the attack
and the court issued preliminary
preliminary ruling according upon russia
to immediately halt to halt the the
attack and withdrawals
and the forwards forces so that that's
who they are at the present time
what do you think obviously as you've
alluded to the international criminal
court preparing a case at currently
there are those however including the uh
the former british prime minister gordon
brown who suggest that the icc might not
be
the best way of dealing with these
alleged war crimes instead perhaps
setting up a a tribe you know what is
your view on that
i think
i i don't think for former prime
minister gordon brown is questioning the
the the capacity uh or the efficiency of
the international criminal court or
jurisdiction
uh to to to bring cases and to
investigate and bring prosecutions uh
against russian leaders for for war
crimes and crimes against humanity
the issue with the the former prime
minister and i i i support it has been
involved with
is that the international criminal court
uh has no jurisdiction over aggression
over the crime of aggression uh be
being committed by russia the crime of
aggression is an attack contrary to the
provisions of the charter of the united
nations to to use military force without
the consent of the security council
or in self-defense and russia's russia's
defense of genocide
is the issue as i've said has been taken
to the international court of justice
but what what is needed is a another
tribunal side by side with the icc
that that is limited to dealing with the
crime of aggression only
that was done that was done in nuremberg
where
where the four four victorious nations
set up the nuremberg trial
brought brought cases against the nazi
leaders of aggression or it was called
in crimes against peace so there's no
there's no question here of second
guessing or in any way diminishing the
important role of the international
criminal court which has jurisdiction
over genocide crimes against humanity
and war crimes the issue is aggression
rishi sunak has fueled hopes he'll slash
petrol duty when he delivers his mini
budget this week the ryan fuel costs
compound a growing cost of living
catastrophe as rocketing inflation is
tipped to hit eight percent within weeks
and of course national insurance heading
for a hike just next month joining us
now on the program the executive
director of the petrol retailers
association gordon balmer gordon good to
see you this morning um i wonder if you
had the same look on your face as i did
when you last went to the petrol pumps
it is getting eye-watering isn't it
absolutely yes and we do recognize that
uh
we don't want to charge these sort of
prices for our customers many of our
members know their customers personally
um so it is not it's not great news at
the moment i'm afraid
how can you just give us a comparison
with other kind of you know compatible
countries across the yes the rest of
europe we we talk often about how the
chancellor has uh held that fuel duty we
have frozen fuel duty for some time but
actually given where it stands as an
international comparison you know isn't
the treasury doing quite well out of all
of this
um well obviously with prices where they
are at the moment they charge 57.95
pence per liter on duty but then they
also tax that as well with an additional
20 percent of vat so
yes from the beginning of the years
we've seen prices escalate um obviously
there's been extra vat revenue returned
to the exchequer so
yes they have um made money out of it
do you think that we could at any point
in the not too distant future see two
pounds a liter
well it depends um i mean we've seen uh
increases of 180 odd dollars a day on
the price of diesel and obviously
similar on petrol in terms of wholesale
prices um so it it it could depending
upon circumstances that uh are going on
in the rest of the world it could go up
to that level uh we hope not um but
uh it's obviously very hard to to
predict at the moment
so what then do you want to hear from
the chancellor come wednesday
suggestions we could see five pence
coming off of fuel jetty but my ready
reckoner that would be what a couple of
quid and i felt on a tank
yeah well we've written to the
chancellor on a number of occasions in
fact three times urging him to cut vat
and fuel duty um we've obviously seen
what other governments around the world
have done particularly our counterparts
in southern ireland with 17 pence off of
their duty for petrol and about 13 pence
off
for diesel so five pence is not as great
as what the irish government have done
the french have done it as well the
dutch government
so we've seen governments try and
alleviate this situation and we're
urging the chancellor to to do what he
can
gordon obama from the petrol retailers
association great to have you on the
show this morning thanks for being with
us thank you
now ukraine has been using social media
extremely effectively throughout the
russian invasion but now they've been
lent a helping hand and a left foot hi
everyone so i'm handing over my social
media to irina the head of the regional
perinatal center in kharkiv ukraine
david beckham handed control of his
instagram account
to a ukrainian doctor working in harkev
yesterday to raise awareness of the
conditions there he wants to use his
account for 71.4 million instagram
followers to highlight the amazing work
of medical staff